congratulations job nomination thank you
we're getting so much love today yes
doing a junket is the right thing to do
the day after you die yeah how do you
guys treat yourself with news like this
do you celebrate you have a spa day like
what's that look like I went straight to
work and I did it like a 16-hour day
yeah so no time for a spa break that my
my little brother is staying with me at
the moment and my cousin and they
actually I came home off like a really
long day yesterday after finding out and
they put gold balloons all in my room it
was so sweet I kind of you know you get
caught up you go straight to work the
next thing you forget to stop and be
like oh wow this year the cool just
happened and so they did that for me
that sounds really nice
I do you do a spa day like a real I I
was lucky I got a shower in yesterday no
I mean listen it's it's it's it's it's a
really nice feeling but my life puts
everything into perspective or really
fast I mean when I found out I was
getting two kids ready for a 7:00 a.m.
pick up a bus pickup and school drop-off
and and then everything after that was
just you know I feel like I'm chasing my
tail and then I'd pick up my
seven-year-old daughter and you know two
teachers called me and she had ended up
being grounded last night and I was just
like I know where's my spa day
celebrating mom today
do I have to deal with you you guys did
great transformations yours you know
being Megan Kelly someone who might not
necessarily be very likable what was it
like for you getting into that character
and what was it like for you just
witnessing that transformation because
your voice changed you look different
it was really cool to see oh um you know
I had a couple of things that I think I
had to get over personally and I think
the more I compartmentalized her in the
story the easier it became for me I
think it was a little overwhelming at
first because it felt like I was kind of
taking on all of megyn kelly and really
what
I was just doing was playing a small
part in this entire story of a year and
a half of what happened at Fox and she's
a small part of that and so once I kind
of understood that it became a little
bit easier to kind of focus the work on
that and and to not hide away from the
warts you know to be able to not to say
that we we went on a journey and we try
to be as truthful as we possibly could
these characters these women are
fascinating they're complex they're
conflicted they don't always do the
right thing there were many times in
this period where they were experiencing
things that I don't think we don't we
just don't talk enough about in society
when it comes to the perplexities of
women and the complexities and they all
lend themselves so beautifully to that
kind of interesting storytelling so we
didn't want I didn't want to throw that
away because she's a polarizing
character I wanted to make that be part
of the storytelling and for me it was
amazing because I'll say this because
Charlize is too humble to say it she
works so freakin hard like so hide you
know when she comes to set she's not
winging it she's not just turning up and
putting on a Meghan voice and doing a
Meghan act she has transformed into
Meghan because she's done hundreds of
hours of work on her accent on her voice
lowing the register the the
transformation that everyone causes we
particularly put in and mapping out the
story and then on the producing side the
amount of research and work they did to
tell this story honestly and and
respectfully is incredible and that was
not missed on any of us awesome thank
you thank you
and I really have